-Our next guest is
an Emmy Award-winning actor
who spent 12 seasons
as one of the stars
of the hit series
"Two and a Half Men."
His new comedy,
"Extended Family,"
airs Tuesday nights
at 8:30 here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Look, I was going
to sleep on this, Julia,
but I'm afraid we have an issue.
I got pulled over
for speeding tonight.
-So you meant you have an issue.
[ Laughs ]
Sorry I'm laughing.
It's happening involuntarily.
How much was the ticket?
-I got off with a warning.
-Did you cry and tell them
that your mom died?
That's what I do.
Come on.
Where's the victory smile?
-My victory smile
is in hibernation,
because we still have an issue,
an issue named Trey.
-How is Trey the issue?
-Your fiance got me off.
-Out. Trey got me
out of the ticket.
-Please welcome back to
the show, Jon Cryer, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Thank you, thank you.
Glad to be back.
-This is a very novel
approach to a sitcom,
because it's about
a divorced couple
that is still amicable,
and historically in sitcoms,
not only do divorced
couples not get along,
most married couples
don't even like each other.
-Exactly, exactly. That's what
we thought was novel about it.
But it's fun.
But it's actually
inspired by the true story
that the owner
of the Boston Celtics,
he and his wife share an
apartment with her ex-husband.
Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
Really thing.
Real thing that happened.
They did it on purpose.
But it's great, actually,
because they are
very good friends.
They did that
so that the kids didn't have
to move back and forth.
-Yeah.
-Which I thought was very novel.
Obviously,
it's not for everybody.
Not everybody can do that.
-Uh-huh. [ Laughs ]
But what the show is about is,
is people trying
to maintain that bit
of friendship that they had
that brought them together
in the first place.
-And your own parents,
they got divorced and also
had a very nice relationship.
-Yes. Thank you for --
Yeah.
-You're very welcome.
You know what?
Thank them.
-I will. I will,
now that you mention it.
No, actually, yeah.
They were divorced when I was
four, and my dad remarried.
My mom and my stepmother
are great friends and hang out.
My half-brothers and sisters
lived in in my mom's house
when they moved to New York.
I mean,
it's crazy hippie [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
Sorry.
But it can work.
It can be great.
And that's
the show we wanted to make.
-You mentioned
the hippie part of it.
Both your parents
were stage actors.
-Yes.
-And so was that
always the plan for you?
-Yeah, it was always
kind of in the background,
because I loved being backstage.
Backstage is just this crazy,
you know -- if you ever get
a chance to do theater,
do it, because --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, no, because
you get backstage,
and it's this wonderful people
and these big personalities
and they're ridiculous,
and I just love that.
But I also sort of wanted
to be an astronaut.
But it was really interesting,
because after
"Two and a Half Men" ended,
I got this request to host an
episode of a documentary series
where I would investigate
the Russian space program.
And I said, "Oh, well,
that sounds fun.
Will you fly me to Moscow
and let me train
to be an astronaut?"
And they said, "Sure."
-Wow.
-So I flew to Moscow
and trained to be an astronaut.
For how long?
-Just for a couple of weeks.
-Okay. That's enough.
-That's really all you need.
But what I learned was,
I would not be
a very good astronaut.
-Oh, interesting.
-Yes, because they don't --
What they don't tell you is,
you know, you see the movies,
and it's just brave people
doing brave things,
and they look all cool,
and everything seems
super competent.
But once you start realizing
that there's certain things
that you have to have a level of
comfort with that you might not.
-Okay. What sort of things
are we talking about?
-Like in the Russian spacecraft
that they send you
to the ISS in,
and they still do this.
They still use the same old ones
that they used back in the '60s.
-Wow.
-Swear to God, they still do.
And they're about this big.
And they jam
three people into that,
and nobody gets a window
or anything.
One guy or gal
gets a thing called a visor,
where they, it's a thing
that they look through
to make sure that the spacecraft
is on the right attitude.
But what they don't tell you
is the visor goes up
between your legs,
and you are jammed like this
wearing a space suit
with two other people right next
to you in something this big,
and then they put you
on top of a rocket
and shoot you out
of the Earth's orbit.
-God.
-The movies
don't have it like that.
-Yeah.
-"Star Trek" is not like that.
Um, so...
so I realized pretty quickly.
And I did the centrifuge.
I did all that, where
it pushes back your face
and all that stuff,
and I felt so badass.
I also did a thing --
They have, their spacesuits,
you know, when you go
outside of the spacecraft,
theirs are different
than the Americans.
They have a door on the back
of their spacesuits
that is -- it's hinged,
and it's like,
you just step in through,
the backpack opens,
and there's the spacesuit,
and you put your legs through,
and then they just go slam,
and slam you inside this thing.
And another thing
they don't tell you,
you know, when you're wearing
a spacesuit in the movies,
it looks all cool.
You look like
the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man.
-Yeah, of course.
-How how hard could that be?
What they don't tell you is,
it's a pressure suit,
so they have to
pump it full of air.
And so you're inflated,
basically.
You're like those guys
that wave at the car wash.
-Yeah. The car wash blow up guy.
-Except yes, you get less
freedom of movement, though.
So you're just ksshhh!
And then just
doing anything at all
is this incredible effort.
And I was like, you know what?
Being an astronaut
requires effort.
No, thank you.
-Yeah.
It feels like if I watch
this documentary,
the takeaway would be,
being an astronaut sucks.
That seems to be --
-Yes.
That's the title of it,
actually.
That's what we ended up with.
But it was interesting to,
something that I had
so many dreams
about as a kid, to go,
"Oh, you know what? No.
No, thanks."
-Well, another dream
for a lot of kids, maybe,
in "Supergirl,"
you got to be Lex Luthor.
-Yes.
-He's a badass.
-He's a total badass.
-So in the same way
that you were saying
astronauts are badass,
and then you actually do it,
and you find out
it's not badass at all,
did you have the same moment
when you got to play Lex Luthor?
-Um...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you.
I'm all about being scary,
I think.
-That's real scary.
That's the scariest Lex Luthor.
"Heyyy, Supergirl."
[ Both laugh ]
-That wasn't exactly --
-"Heyyy, Supergirl!"
-That wasn't my reading,
just so you know.
But no, actually,
we were about to do a stunt,
which is very manly and badass.
I was hanging from
a helicopter in green screen,
so you're about a foot
and a half off the ground.
But it looked great
in the end, Seth.
-You were in "Superman 4"?
-Yes.
-Lenny was your character.
-I was Lenny Luthor.
I played my own nephew.
It's like inception.
-So you must have been
a very young actor at the time.
-Yeah, yeah. I was 21.
-Okay,
so you're in "Superman 4."
And did you learn
anything as a young actor
doing a giant superhero movie?
-Oh, well, there's a lot of
flying in "Superman 4."
-One of the main parts.
-It's a Superman movie.
Exactly.
And I was so excited about that.
You see the movies, you know,
like, in the first movie,
Superman, they --
it was beautiful flying,
it was balletic.
-Yeah.
-I get there on the first day,
and the stunt coordinator
is the guy
who's a legend
in the area of flying stuff.
He's amazing, a British guy.
And he says, "Okay, one thing
you have to be aware of --"
I'm not doing a good
British accent at all.
"Is that when they
put the harness on you" --
this is 1987, I think --
"When they put
the harness on you,
they have to cinch it
incredibly tight,
so it will catch any hair
that you have on there."
So he said, "You may want
to take care of any hair
that you have,
either on the back
or on the front, either way,
so that it doesn't catch
in the harness.
And I thought, oh, okay.
So I got rid of everything.
Nair came into play.
Nair is a very specific '80s
reference for you guys.
And did the thing,
and smooth as glass, I did.
I was very excited.
I mean, both the shot
and my --
-Regions.
But what I did not realize
was that the painful stuff is,
you know, is delayed,
because what I learned is,
when your butt hair grows back,
it hurts.
-Oh!
-Yes.
This is just --
I don't know if any--
I hope America does not
have to experience this,
but when your your
butt hair grows back,
it is no fun for anyone.
And actually, Melissa Benoist,
who was Supergirl,
the first day of work, I said,
"Hey, I know we're going to be
doing some flying stuff.
Do we still have to do that?"
And she was like, "No!"
This guy was clearly
pulling a prank, apparently.
[ Laughter ]
-Pretty good prank.
-It's a pretty good prank.
Pretty good.
-Pretty good prank.
-Yep. He got me good.
-There you go.
Well, thank you
for being with us and sharing.
I mean, I think
if there was a PSA,
it's like, don't be an astronaut
and never shave your butt hair.
-Yes.
-Thank you. Thank you so much.
-Thank you.
-Jon Cryer, everybody.
[ Applause ]
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."